hey guys it is Tuesday my name is Jess
and I heard yesterday Dan tried to bribe
his way into your heart with game codes
but I told him our love is too pure and
genuine for that try to find you some
game codes look I'm not technically
responsible for this one but you can go
play a free demo of mafia 3 right now
which is pretty cool the trial is
available on ps4 xbox one and pc and
weighs in at around twenty five
gigabytes depending on your platform
you'll be able to play the first act of
the game which features a bank heist
gone wrong and sets up the rest of the
story it's actually really quite good if
you haven't played it so go check it out
for none of your dollars if you keen on
it and end up grabbing the full version
your progress will carry over so you can
keep on grooving to some of the best
music that's been featured in a video
game the full game is half off until
April seventeenth alongside the free
demo mafia threes latest DLC has also
been released faster baby adds new cars
a new weapon to like proximity mines and
the ability to throw grenades while
driving finally faster baby is included
with mafia 3 sdlc pass for thirty bucks
the $80 deluxe edition or on its own for
15 bucks next up psionics may be kicking
into gear to bring rocket league to
nintendo switch maybe here's what we
know vice president of psionics Jeremy
Dunham told IGN just like all the other
platforms we are evaluating it we're
looking to see what the technical
requirements are adding we're looking to
see what kind of true community demand
there is looking to see how it would
benefit the community as a whole so like
I said maybe the company's latest data
has shown that car soccer has 29 million
registered players and is sold 10.5
million copies worldwide across all
platforms it's not all been hugs and
puppies for psionics though as rocket
League has been facing some nasty server
issues like crazy long loading times for
matchmaking and server outages to this
point psionics have said the issues are
totally unacceptable and a pledge to
address and improve them finally Bungie
have released a teaser video with
destiny 2 1 buzzer which has some pretty
into
informations the video which features
robot Nathan Fillion has the hunter
vanguard of recounting a gun-slinging
story in a destroyed bar those shooting
noises a robot sweeping and an
announcement of a full trailer coming
this thursday March 30th interestingly
the PlayStation version of the trailer
has a few extra seconds at the end the
end screen you're looking at now teases
exclusive content for destiny to on ps4
but if we zoom in enhance the fine print
reveals that it's timed explosive
content until at least full 2018 with
more details to be released this summer
we're still without an official release
date for destiny too but we'll have all
the news for you as it happens so be
sure to subscribe that is everything
I've got for you today do let me know
what you cared about down in that
comment box head to gamespot for all the
latest news and features and I will see
you again tomorrow